VI made an interesting tweet uh I think
it was yesterday he said if you think
that Donald Trump or Joe Biden are
getting anywhere near the White House
what is wrong with you like the way he
phrased it was like there's no way in
hell that's going to happen Trump or
Biden yeah he's kind of like I think
he's he sees something about the way
that the Deep State works and the way
that the powers of be kind of want the
situation to go and they are the ones
with all the secret police so he just
kind of consigned himself to it I don't
know if the tweet's still up I'm looking
for it it's about about you sure it's a
real tweet uh someone made a fake one
here it is it's from 20 hours ago from
VI on his page if you really if you
really think quote they are going to let
either Trump or Biden get anywhere near
the Finish Line open your eyes folks
there's something deeper going on it's
starting it's staring us right in the
face but who is they though yeah who is
they put it in quotes thank you yay for
giving us that mem and it it could be
way bigger than the American deep state
it could be even bigger than that who
knows